what's the most positive thing you've
heard someone in the industry say to you
I had a director that I really respect
her name is Nina NEMA Barnett and she's
like a pioneering african american
director first woman african-american
woman ever directed network television
show i worked with on a project and she
pulled me aside and she said you're
really good and I thought you know
coming from her she's been in the
industry 25 years and she's worked with
like really good actors hey that made my
you know that made my my millennium and
I you know and I thought if I never get
another comment like that for as long as
i work at least I got one but you know
coming from her that made me feel really
good thank you you know if after you'd
perform and I like the most like amazing
comment ever gotten us I I did a scene
in college and it's like it came in such
a great feedback and as well thank you
very much for that Eve actually no no
thank you for allowing me to watch you
perform that like this as an artist as
an actor like that just like meant the
world to me you know there's there's a
lot of stereotypes and acting like you
must play the white girl with the white
you know try to play dumb surprisingly I
remembered did this acting on monologue
thing and I have to be this like
stereotypical like oh my god white girl
you know and um I did a really good job
at I was really happy and my my teacher
loved what I did and he told he kept the
tape I mean like that felt so good to me
that I practiced so hard on that a
monologue and finally like even though
I'm Filipino I could play a different
role like that I'm always so bad
literally all journals of people wear
this Caucasian Asian African American
whatever on that I have beautiful a
beautiful collection so I got that a lot
and you know doing the modeling and
acting on the east coast while pursuing
in school when someone says you know I
love what you do but you are great at
what you
that is the best compliment I have ever
heard and it's just someone appreciating
the work I put into it you know it's
saying that was you made the character
proud that's basically what it is making
the character proud I think I got cast
as an Asian ones like ad for an Asian
role which made me really happy because
I didn't really look asian but I guess
they saw it somehow like a little bit of
my eyes and something there's like okay
you can have the part it was like for a
remake of this Japanese TV series that's
very popular over there and they wanted
to cast it with mostly agents and so I
got a part in that so I was like really
happy I had a meeting with an agent you
know one time and and and she said I
don't even see you as an asian american
actor I don't know if that's positive or
not that's the other side of the coin is
that I see you as more of a you know a
different type you know but there aren't
a lot of rolls out there to to sort of
serve that that appetite but I think
positive things are just that he's a
great actor that he's professional that
he's you know generous and and and you
know and and kind and supportive you
know those are there's a wonderful
things for me to hear you know and they
don't really have anything to do with
race it has to do with who you are as an
actor or as a professional this one time
I paid at the range stuff husband
and I not only made my my wife you know
cry you know naturally but she was
hysterical she was shaking she was in so
much fear that she didn't know what to
do and and yeah you know at the time I
felt bad and then it was one time she
slapped me and then I felt the urge to
slap her back and I did and then she
slapped me and I understood i'm like i
shouldn't be doing this and I apologized
not as not as attitude oh but as a
character you know because it felt
natural to do so but i didn't i didn't
apologize because I found out that
that's the best you know seeing that
she's done it she's got the most alive
and it was just it was real if it wasn't
real and I slapped her then you know it
doesn't make any sense to do so so yeah
I mean there's no apologies i mean
everything worked out good even better
than then it was written